SENATE EDUCATION COMMITTEE WE
HAVE SIX BILLS ON THE AGENDA
TODAY ITEM THREE SB ONE FORTY
EIGHT BY CENTER GLAZER HAS BEEN
PULLED AT THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHOR.
AS BEFORE --
EXCUSE ME ITEM FOR AS TO ONE
FIFTY BY SENATOR BILL HAS ALSO
BEEN PULLED AT THE REQUEST OF
THE AUTHOR.
AND ITEM SIX S. C. R. SIX BY
SENATOR NIELSEN IS ON CONSENT SO
WE DON'T HAVE A QUORUM BUT
SENATOR ROBB A SEE YOU THERE
PLEASE COME ON UP [inaudible]
WELCOME.
THANK YOU A MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
FIRST LET ME.
SAY BEFORE I FORGET THAT --
I AM DELIGHTED TO ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEES PROPOSED AMENDMENT TO
TO THE BILL REGARDING REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS THANK YOU SIR.
AS YOU KNOW IT'S BEEN WIDELY
REPORTED THAT OUR SUPPLY OF OF
PRIMARY CARE PHYSICIANS IN THE
STATE IS SIGNIFICANTLY BELOW
WHAT'S CONSIDERED ADEQUATE TO
MEET PATIENT NEEDS AT THE SAME
TIME AS WE'RE PRESSING TO
INCREASE COVERAGE UP AND DOWN
THE STATE.
PROMISING.
THOUSANDS IF NOT MILLIONS OF
PEOPLE THAT THEY WILL GET CARE
WHEN THE SUPPLY OF PRIMARY CARE
PHYSICIANS IS SIMPLY NOT THERE
IN ORDER.
TO PROVIDE THE CARE PARTICULARLY
IN SOME GEOGRAPHIC REGIONS OF
THE STATE THE SITUATION IS EVEN
MORE DIRE IN INLAND SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA WITH JUST THIRTY FIVE
PRIMARY CARE PHYSICIANS PER ONE
HUNDRED THOUSAND PATIENTS FAR
FEWER THAN THE RECOMMENDED.
RANGE OF SIXTY TO EIGHTY PRIMARY
CARE PHYSICIANS PER THAT SAME
ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND POPULATION
GIVEN THE CURRENT TREND TO THEY
SAY THAT WE WILL BE FOUR
THOUSAND TO EIGHT THOUSAND
PRIMARY CARE PHYSICIAN SHORT IN
THIS STATE.
OVER THE NEXT DECADE OR TWO SO.
WHAT DO WE DO ABOUT IT AND HOW
DO WE REVERSE THAT TREND WILL WE
SEE YOU --
STARTED IN TWO THOUSAND AND
THIRTEEN BY AUTHORIZING THE
INITIAL STATE FUNDING FOR THE
MEDICAL SCHOOL AT THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA RIVERSIDE.
UCR'S FOR YEARS SCHOOL OF
MEDICINE.
TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN AND WHEN
IT OPENED IT WAS THE FIRST NEW
PUBLIC MEDICAL SCHOOL IN THIS
STATE IN MORE THAN FORTY YEARS.
SINCE ITS OPENING THE SCHOOL HAS
GRADUATED EIGHTY NINE STUDENTS
WITH MD DEGREES FORTY IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN FORTY NINE
AND TWO THOUSAND AND EIGHTEEN
BUT WE CLEARLY NEED MORE GIVEN
THE STATISTICS THAT I REFERENCED.
DUE TO BUDGETARY CONSTRAINTS AT
THE TIME YOU SEE ARE SCHOOL OF
MEDICINE WAS FORCED TO OCCUPY AN
EXISTING FACILITY ON YOU SEE
OURS CAMPUS.
WHICH UNFORTUNATELY HAS LIMITED
ITS CLASS SIZE TO ABOUT SIXTY
STUDENTS PER ACADEMIC YEAR.
AND OF COURSE STATE FUNDING TO
SUPPORT THE MEDICAL SCHOOL HAS
BEEN LIMITED TO FIFTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS FOR FISCAL YEAR.
IMPACTING THE SCHOOL'S ABILITY
TO REALIZE ITS PUBLIC MISSION.
IT'S IMPORTANT I THINK FOR THE
COMMITTEE TO NOTE THAT IS MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT.
MOST OTHER PUBLIC MEDICAL
SCHOOLS IN THE UNITED STATES ARE
SCALED TO ONE HUNDRED AND TWENTY
STUDENTS PER CLASS OR MORE.
EXPANSION OF THIS USE YOUR
MEDICAL SCHOOL IS URGENTLY
NEEDED IN ORDER TO INCREASE THE
SUPPLY OF PRIMARY CARE
PHYSICIANS.
UP AND DOWN THE STATE NOW FROM A
POLICY PERSPECTIVE I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT THE BILL
WOULD APPROVE THE EXPANSION OF
THE YOU SEE ARE SCHOOL OF
MEDICINE.
FROM ABOUT TWO HUNDRED FIFTY TO
FIVE HUNDRED STUDENTS IF
APPROPRIATE AT A COST OF EIGHTY
MILLION DLLARS.
AND WOULD INCREASE THE ANNUAL
OPERATIONAL FUNDING TO SUPPORT
THAT EXPANSION AGAIN F
APPROPRIATED THAT TWENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS I HAVE. TWO
WITNESSES WITH ME TODAY DEAN
DEPUTIES THE DATE OF THE USE
YOUR MEDICAL SCHOOL TO PROVIDE
SOME BRIEF COMMENTS AND ANSWER
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS.
AND ONE OF YOU SEE OURS
OUTSTANDING AREAS TO OFFER SOME
BRIEF COMMENTS AS WELL MADAM
CHAIR THANK YOU CENTER ROTH AND
BEFORE WE GET TO YOUR WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT I NOTICE A QUORUM SO
MADAM SECRETARY WOULD YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL LEYVA.
HERE LEYVA HERE WILL PRESENT
WILK HERE CHIANG RUSSELL.
RUSSELL HERE GLAZER GLAZER HERE
MCGUIRE CAN.
CAN HERE.
THANK YOU PLEASE PROCEED.
NEAR ME NOTE TRY ONE THERE WE GO
ON NOW YOU'LL BE FINE THEY'RE A
LITTLE TRICKY THANK YOU SENATOR
ROSS.
SENATE TO LEYVA AND MEMBERS OF
THE SENATE EDUCATION COMMITTEE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR ATTENTION TO
THE HEALTHCARE WORKFORCE NEEDS
OF SOME OF CALIFORNIA.
I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO THANK
SENATOR ROTH FOR INTRODUCING SB
FIFTY SIX AND ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
JOSE MEDINA AND SABRINA
CERVANTES FOR SERVING AS
PRINCIPAL COAUTHORS.
YOU SEE OUR ESTABLISH A
COMMUNITY BASED MEDICAL SCHOOL.
WITH A MISSION OF EXPANDING AND
DIVERSIFYING THE PHYSICIAN
WORKFORCE OF INLAND SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
WHILE WE ARE YOUNG MEDICAL
SCHOOL I AM PLEASED TO REPORT
THAT WE HAVE ALREADY MADE A DOWN
PAYMENT ON THIS MISSION.
ALL STUDENTS ARE RACIALLY AND
ETHNICALLY DIVERSE COME FROM
DISADVANTAGED BACKGROUNDS AND
INCLUDE MANY STUDENTS WHO ARE
THE FIRST IN THEIR FAMILIES TO
COMPLETE A BACHELOR'S DEGREE.
ALL STUDENTS IN BODY THE
COMMUNITY OF FUTURE PHYSICIANS
THAT WE ARE TRAINING.
THIS IS IMPORTANT BECAUSE ONE OF
THE PRINCIPAL DRIVERS OF WHERE
PHYSICIAN PRACTICES IS WHERE HE
AYE SHE GREW UP.
AND COMPLETED TRAINING.
UP THE GRADUATES AND SOON TO BE
GRADUATES MORE THAN 80% ARE
PURSUING RESIDENCY TRAINING IN
CALIFORNIA.
WITH MORE THAN TWO THIRDS
REMAINING IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
AND NEARLY A THIRD IN THE INLAND
SAID IN CALIFORNIA I INLAND
EMPIRE.
THE STATE INVESTMENT IN THIS
MEDICAL SCHOOL IS PAYING
DIVIDENDS FOR OUR POSITION
WORKFORCE NEEDS.
AND ESPECIALLY THE NEEDS OF THE
REGION.
THE ADDITIONAL INVESTMENT
PROVIDED IN SB FIFTY SIX BOTH
THE ONGOING OPERATING FUNDS AND
THE BUILDING IS ABSOLUTELY
NECESSARY. TO ALLOW YOU SEE ARE
SCHOOL OF MEDICINE TO FULLY
REALIZE THIS MISSION.
THIS PROPOSAL ALIGNS WITH THE
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THE
CALIFORNIA FUTURE HEALTH FORCE
WORK COMMISSION.
THE COMMISSION IN PART CALLED
FOR INCREASED PROMINENCE
OPERATING RESOURCES TO EXPAND
YOU SEE ARE SCHOOL OF MEDICINE
SAN ROMAN.
AND A CAPITAL INVESTMENT TO IN
ABLE TO GROW.
WE ARE GRATIFIED BY THE
COMMISSION'S RECOGNITION OF HOW
YOU SEE ARE SCHOOL OF MEDICINE
CAN CONTRIBUTE TO SOLVING THE
HEALTH WORKFORCE SHORTAGE.
TODAY YOU'LL ALSO BE HEARING
FROM ONE OF PHAM MEDICAL STUDENT
FRANCISCO FOR FAR YES.
WHO WILL BE GRADUATING MAY
THIRTY FIRST HE IS FROM THE
INLAND EMPIRE ATTENDED YOU SEE
ARE SCHOOL OF MEDICINE AND WILL
BE TRAINING IN A PRIMARY CARE
FIELD?
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
OF SB FIFTY SIX AND I AM PLEASED
TO ADDRESS YOUR QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU WELCOME PLEASE PROCEED.
THANK YOU.
OKAY.
HI GOOD MORNING HONORABLE CHAIR --
CENTER EARLY BY MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
MY NAME IS FRANCISCO FOR THE US
AND I AM CURRENTLY A FOURTH YEAR
MEDICAL STUDENT AT THE UC OUR
SCHOOL OF MEDICINE.
BY TWO THIRDS OF MY COLLEAGUES I
HAVE ALSO STRONG TIES TO THE
INLAND SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
REGION.
I GREW UP IN RIVERSIDE COUNTY
AND ATTENDED NORCO HIGH SCHOOL
AND AFTERWARDS CAME TO MY DEGREE
IN BIOLOGICAL SCIENCES FROM
CALIFORNIA POLYTECHNIC STATE
UNIVERSITY IN POMONA.
WHEN I HEARD THAT YOU SEE ARE
WAS OPENING THEIR VERY OWN
MEDICAL SCHOOL I WAS ECSTATIC?
BECAUSE IT WOULD NOT ONLY FOR ME
THE OPPORTUNITY TO LEARN AND
PRACTICE MEDICINE.
BUT IT WOULD ALLOW ME TO GIVE
BACK TO THE COMMUNITY THAT
RAISED ME.
AS THE FIRST GENERATION MEXICAN
AMERICAN IN THE FIRST PERSON IN
MY FAMILY TO ATTEND COLLEGE.
I CAN NEVER IMAGINED ATTENDING A
FOR YOUR MEDICAL SCHOOL
ESPECIALLY MY OWN COMMUNITY.
CAN I CAN DECLARE WITH GREAT
PRIDE THAT USE YOUR SCHOOL
MEDICINE.
I AM NOT THE EXCEPTION.
RATHER I AM PART OF THE DIVERSE
AND REALLY GROUP STRIVING TO
IMPROVE THE HEALTH OF OUR
SURROUNDING COMMUNITIES.
DO NOT TAKE MY WORD FOR IT FOR
THE NUMBERS SPEAK FOR THEMSELVES.
40% OF MY COVERT ARE UNDER
REPRESENTED IN MEDICINE 56% OF
OUR CLASSES PRICE OF FUTURE
WOMEN DOCTORS.
AND 40% OF MY COLLEAGUES HAIL
FROM EDUCATIONALLY AND OR SOCIAL
ECONOMICALLY DISADVANTAGED
BACKGROUNDS.
I BELIEVE THAT A DIVERSE
WORKFORCE IS ESSENTIAL TO
HELPING THE AFOREMENTIONED
POPULATIONS NOT ONLY IN THE
REGION BUT THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE
STATE AS WELL.
AND THIS IS ONE OF THE MANY
AREAS AT WHICH YOU SEE OUR
EXCELS.
IN ADDITION AS A MEDICAL STUDENT
I PARTICIPATED IN THE MARRIOTT
OF OPPORTUNITIES THAT SERVE THE
SURROUNDING COMMUNITY.
THE FREE CLINICS IN RIVERSIDE
SAN BERNARDINO IN THE COACHELLA
VALLEY'S WELL.
AND THIS ALLOWED US TO PROVIDE
FREE HEALTH CARE TO A POPULATION
WHICH OTHERWISE WOULD NOT HAVE
ACCESS TO QUALITY CARE.
ALL THESE EXPERIENCES SERVE TO
DEFINE MY FUTURE AMBITIONS AND
ETHOS IS A POSITION.
HAVING RECENTLY COMPLETED MY
RESIDENCY INTERVIEWS.
I HAD THE PLEASURE SPEAKING WITH
MEDICAL STUDENTS FROM ALL ACROSS
THE COUNTRY CAN I QUICKLY
REALIZED THAT YOU SEE ARE IS A
SPECIAL PLACE COMMITTED TO THREE
PRONG MISSION OF SERVICE
TEACHING AND RESEARCH.
I AM CURRENTLY PURSUING A
RESIDENCY IN GENERAL INTERNAL
MEDICINE THAT ALLOWS ME TO BUILD
ME FORM LASTING RELATIONSHIPS
WITH MY PATIENTS AND MY
COMMUNITY.
AS I DISCOVERED THROUGHOUT MY
FOUR YEARS OF HIGH CALIBER
MEDICAL EDUCATION AT UC
RIVERSIDE.
THIS IS THE ESSENCE OF MY JOY
AND SATISFACTION MEDICINE.
MORE IMPORTANTLY I ONCE IN A
MORE THAN READY TO SERVE IN THE
INLAND SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
REGION.
WHICH IS AND WILL FOREVER REMAIN
MY HOME.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SHARE MY EXPERIENCE AND I URGE
THE COMMITTEE TO SUPPORT SENATE
BILL.
FIFTY SIX AND HELP US TO
CONTINUE TO BUILD THE TEXT AND
RATIONS OF PHYSICIANS AND EXPAND
ACCESS TO QUALITY HEALTHCARE IN
OUR REGION.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FRANCISCO AS A
RESIDENT OF MAKING US ALL PROUD
HAPPY TO HAVE YOU HERE TODAY.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS --
JEFF AKA REPRESENTING THE
RIVERSIDE COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT
OF SCHOOLS ON THE TWENTY THREE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS SUPERINTENDENTS
AND THE COUNTY.
US SENATOR ROTH HAS OUTLINED THE
GREAT NEED FOR ADDITIONAL
MEDICAL PROFESSIONALS IN THE
INLAND EMPIRE --
WE SUPPORT THE BILL BECAUSE WE
RECOGNIZE THAT THERE IS A WELL
DOCUMENTED LINK BETWEEN STUDENT
WELLNESS AN ACADEMIC ACHIEVEMENT.
BUT WE SEE THE FURTHER
DEVELOPMENT OF THE MEDICAL
SCHOOL AS IMPROVING THE QUALITY
OF LIFE OF FAMILIES AND CHILDREN.
AND THEN WE ALSO SEE IT AS
INCREASING OPPORTUNITIES FOR OUR
STUDENTS --
WITH REGARD TO THE DEVELOPMENT
OF CAREER PATHWAYS AND
EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMS THAT ARE
ASSOCIATED WITH THE VARIOUS
MEDICAL FIELDS.
SO WE THANK SENATOR ROTH FOR
BEING A CHAMPION OF THE PROJECT
AND ARE PLEASED TO SUPPORT THE
BILL.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU OTHERS IN
SUPPORT.
FORGET TO HAVE ANYONE IN SUPPORT
FROM THE AUDIENCE.
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME AND
ORGANIZATION.
MAX PAVE THE CITY OF RIVERSIDE
ALSO IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT SEEING NO OTHERS IS
THERE ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING AND HEARING NO ONE
SENATOR ROTH WHICH I TOOK WELL
BEFORE YOU CLOSE SORRY.
TAKE BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
CENTER PAN.
THANK THANK YOU SO MUCH TERROR
LEYVA --
FIRST OF ALL I WANT THANK YOU
CENTER OFFER BRING THIS BEFORE
US -- AS A
MEDICAL EDUCATOR I WAS SIR YOU
SEE DAVIS AND SERVED ON THE
ACGME BOARD AND HOW IMPORTANT
MEDICAL EDUCATION IS.
IN TERMS OF OUR WORK FOR SUPPLY.
I GUESS ONE QUESTIONS AFTER THE
DEAN IS IS THAT --
THAT.
CAN YOU JUST MAYBE TOUCH A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT --
IN TERMS OF YOUR FUNDING
RELATION TO TEACHING HOSPITALS
AND YOUR RELATIONSHIP WITH --
THE ENTRY OF THE CLINICAL
CAPACITY SO PART OF THE TRAINING
IS NOT JUST LECTURE HALLS TO
GIVE TALKS A IT'S ALSO ABOUT YOU
KNOW HAVING CLINICAL SITES FOR
ALL THE STUDENTS TO BE ABLE IT
IN TERMS OF THE EXPANSION.
SELECTED AVAILABILITY CLINICAL
SITES THANK YOU FOR ASKING THAT
QUESTION BECAUSE IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT THAT IT'S MEDICAL
STUDENT TRAINING IT'S NOT JUST
THE IN CLASS SOME EDUCATION.
BUT WE HAVE TO HAVE A CLINICAL
PLATFORM FOR ALL STUDENTS TO
LEARN THAT CLINICAL SKILLS AND
WHAT'S UNIQUE ABOUT YOU SEE ARE
SCHOOL OF MEDICINE.
IS THAT OUR STUDENTS BEGAN TO
GET CLINICAL EXPERIENCE ONE
MONTH ACTED THEY MATRICULATED
INTO MEDICAL SCHOOL WE ASSIGN
THEM TO VARIOUS POSITIONS IN THE
AREA AND THEY STAY WITH THAT
POSITION. FOR THREE YEARS BEFORE
PLATFORM REQUIRES US TO FORM
MULTIPLE AFFILIATIONS WITH
VARIOUS HOSPITALS AS WELL AS
HAVING A CLINICAL PLATFORM AT UC
RIVERSIDE.
OKAY SO IT BASICALLY THAT'S THAT
CERTAINLY --
AT ONE POINT ELEMENT I DISCUSS
WHAT PEOPLE UNDERSTAND THAT --
THIS IS WELL CERTAINLY VITAL
FUNDING FOR SOME OF THE
INFRASTRUCTURE THERE'S ACTUALLY
A LARGER COMMUNITY
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT YOU HAVE
THAT YOU TAP INTO. TO TO TRAIN
OUR STUDENTS AND OF ITS GO
THANKS SO MUCH FOR BEING HERE
ACTUALLY --
DO YOU MIND IF YOU DO I SHOW
THIS FOR YOU MATCHED AND I KNOW
MATCH DAY WAS THAT LAST WEEK.
YEAH ABSOLUTELY SO I ENDED UP
MATCHING TO UNIVERSITY OF
WASHINGTON IN SEATTLE FOR
INTERNAL MEDICINE OKAY.
AND A GREAT PROGRAM OF THEIR
BILL EXPECTING TO COME BACK.
ON AND SO WHAT THAT --
AGAIN I THINK THIS IS IMPORTANT
I WOULD POINT OUT THAT --
AND THAT'S YOU KNOW A FULL SIZE
MEDICAL SCHOOL YOU'RE RIGHT
GENERALLY YOU'RE PROBABLY
TALKING ABOUT IN THE LONG YOU
KNOW ONE HUNDRED HUNDRED TWENTY
ANY SOME SCHOOLS OF COURSE
LARGER --
GENERATES ABOUT --
CAN GENERATE YOU KNOW OVER
BILLION SOMETHING AVERAGE TWO
BILLION --
OF ECONOMIC ACTIVITY AND THE
REGION SO THAT THAT'S ALSO AND
VERY IMPORTANT ECONOMIC DRIVER.
FOR FOR THE COMMUNITY AS WELL SO
WITH THAT I'D BE HAPPY MOVE AT
THE PROFIT TIME.
THANK YOU SENATOR PAN SENATOR
DORADO.
YES THANK YOU IS IT FORTY S.
IDEA STATUS OF THANK YOU MISTER
FOR THE S. AND SENATOR ROTHSTEIN
EVERYONE WHO'S HERE.
THIS IS REALLY A GREAT UP
PROPOSAL --
BUT I WANT TO ASK YOU AND IN
PARTICULAR --
AS WE LOOK TO AS YOU LOOK TO
DOUBLE THE NUMBER OF STUDENTS
THOUGHT THROUGH THIS PROPOSAL.
AND WE HAVE SUCH A GREAT NEED
ACROSS THE STATE THIS WILL BE
STATEWIDE.
WHAT WOULD YOU DO?
ANY ONE THING THAT THE SCHOOL
COULD DO TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE ENOUGH DIVERSITY.
COMING IN YOU KNOW A POOL.
OF A DIVERSE STUDENTS --
SO THAT THEY CAN GO TO THE
SCHOOL AND GRADUATING COME BACK
AS AS YOU SAID BECAUSE WE HAVE
SUCH A GREAT NEED ALL OVER.
WHETHER TO EAST LA OR FRESNO SO
MANY PARTS OF THE STATE WHERE WE
HAVE A NEED FOR DOCTORS --
SO WHAT WOULD YOU DO ON THAT. TO
INCREASE THE NUMBER SET THE AND
UP.
WITH SMALLER NUMBERS AT YOUR
LOCAL.
YES ABSOLUTELY SO I THINK THE
STRATEGY OUR SCHOOL IS IS TAKEN
UP TO THIS POINT --
HAS BEEN REALLY PHENOMENAL IN
THE SENSE THAT.
THEY REALLY FOCUSING IN ON
GIVING PRIORITY TO RESIDENTS OF
THE SAY WHO HAVE STRONG TIES TO
THE REGION.
AND I THINK THAT THAT TRULY DOES
PER ME AS FAR AS WHAT THE FUTURE
AMBITIONS ALL OF OUR CLASS ARE
AS THE HOLES.
I WOULD CONTINUE.
TO SELECT STUDENTS WITH THAT
TYPE OF FILTER IN MIND --
IT'S BUILT IN IN INTO OUR
INTERVIEW PROCESS I HAD THE
PLEASURE OF INTERVIEWING A
PROSPECTIVE STUDENTS WHO ARE
APPLYING OUR MEDICAL SCHOOL IN
IT VERY MUCH IS ENTRENCHED.
INTO THE SELECTION PROCESS IS
TRYING TO PICK OUT THE STUDENTS
THAT WE FEEL DEMONSTRATE A
COMMITMENT NOT ONLY TO THE
MISSION BUT TO THE AREA.
I THINK IN DOING SO --
IT DOES SELECT FOR A GROUP OF
INDIVIDUALS WHO.
ARE MORE PRONE TO REALLY
ENTRENCHING THEMSELVES IN THE
COMMUNITY AND TAKING ADVANTAGE
OF THE VARIOUS --
OPPORTUNITIES THAT THERE ARE IN
THE COMMUNITY TO SERVE THAT FOR
THERE'D BE FREE CLINICS --
BECAUSE THIS IS A UNIQUE
EXPERIENCES YOU WANTED TAILORED
TOWARDS PEOPLE WHO WANT THAT
EXPERIENCE.
THANK YOU.
ADD TO THAT PLEASE YES PLEASE
SURE.
I'M I'D JUST LIKE TO ADD THAT
YOU SEE ARE SCHOOL OF MEDICINE
IS VERY ENGAGED IN THE COMMUNITY
AND AS SUCH WE'RE FEELING THAT
WE ARE GROWING OUR OWN.
BEING THAT WE ARE BUILDING A
PIPELINE OF STUDENTS WE HAVE
PIPELINE PROGRAMS THAT GO ALL
THE WAY TO ELEMENTARY SCHOOL
WE'RE NOT WAITING FOR STUDENTS
TO GET TO COLLEGE AND ASKING
THEM.
TO ENGAGE HER THINK ABOUT
HEALTHCARE THE HEALTHCARE FIELD.
SO ALL PIPELINE PROGRAM IS
EXTENSIVE WE SEE AN AVERAGE OF
ALMOST A THOUSAND STUDENTS
WITHIN THE YEAR.
AND WE UTILIZE SOME OF OUR
CURRENT MEDICAL STUDENTS TO GO
INTO THE SCHOOLS WITH US IN INTO
THE COMMUNITIES WITH US SO THAT
THOSE STUDENTS CAN SEE WHAT THEY
CAN BE.
AND THEY LOOK AT OUR STUDENTS AS
ROLE MODELS AND THEY BECOME
ENTHUSIASTIC AND ENGAGE IN
INTERESTED IN PURSUING CAREERS
IN THE HEALTHCARE FIELD.
A GOOD THANK YOU CENTER GLAZER.
THANK YOU CHAIR --
SENATE ROTH I JUST WANTED TO ADD
MY VOICE OF FABRICATION FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP IN THIS --
THIS AREA AND FOR THE C. R.
SCHOOL OF MEDICINE --
YOUR PASSION FOR THE SCHOOL AND
ITS MISSION AND ITS WORK IS
UNLIMITED IN FACT --
WE HAVE ANY COVERSATIONS IN THE
COURSE OF OUR LEGISLATIVE LIFE
AND I THINK THAT --
EVERY OTHER ONE I THINK YOU TO
ME ABOUT YOUR MEDICAL SCHOOL --
AND RIVERSIDE AND HOW MUCH HOW
IMPORTANT IT IS AND HOW --
HOW MUCH YOU WANT TO SEE IT GROW
AND EXPAND IN AND SERVE THE
LOCAL COMMUNITY AND ALL OF US IN
OUR STATE SO I COMMEND YOU ON
THIS BILL?
AND I'M HAPPY TO SUPPORT IT AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME.
THANK YOU CENTER GLAZER I TOO
WOULD JUST LIKE TO SAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SENATOR ROTH AS
SOMEONE WHO LIVES IN THE INLAND
EMPIRE AND DOES A SHORT ISSUE WE
HAVE I APPRECIATE YOUR STEADFAST
SUPPORT OF MAKING SURE WE HAVE.
NOT JUST THE MONEY TO SUPPORT
THE SCHOOL BUT THAT WE ARE
GROWING OUR OWN AND PUTTING THEM
BACK INTO THE COMMUNITY.
SO WITH THAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE.
WELL THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR FIRST
AYE I JUST WANT TO SAY I THINK
YOU CAN SEE.
WHY WE ARE SO PROUD OF OUR
EXTRAORDINARY MEDICAL SCHOOL
DEAN AND OUR STUDENTS?
BUT AS I NOTED WE HAVE A
HEALTHCARE CRISIS WE'RE IN
ROLLING MORE MORE AND MORE
PEOPLE INSURANCE WE'RE EXPANDING
ATTEMPTING TO EXPAND COVERAGE WE
HAVE A INCREASING SHORTAGE OF
PRIMARY.
CARE PHYSICIANS IS ONLY GETTING
WORSE AND I THINK WE NEED TO FIX
THIS.
AND WE NEED TO START FIXING IT
RIGHT NOW SO I THANK YOU FOR
YOUR SUPPORT AND I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR ROTH WE HAVE A
MOTION BY DOCTOR PAN MA'AM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ITEM TO SB FIFTY SIX THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS LEYVA.
HI LEYVA AYE IT WELL HI WILK I
CHIANG TO WRESTLE. TO WRESTLE
AYE GLAZER.
GLAZER AYE MCGUIRE PAN THE BILL
HAS ENOUGH VOTES TO GET OUT BUT
WE WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU CENTER
ROCKY MANAGER MEMBERS.
SENATOR HILL ARE YOU READY.
GOOD MORNING GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR AND AN MEMBERS --
I INVITE YOU TO START WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY I APPRECIATE THAT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF THIS BILL
A SB TWO TWENTY THREE MAY LOOK
FAMILIAR TO MANY OF YOU IT WAS A
PASSED OUT OF THIS COMMITTEE
LAST YEAR --
AND IT IS --
DESIGNED TO HELP STUDENTS WITH
SEVERE MEDICAL DISABILITIES
ATTEND SCHOOL OFTEN THE ONLY
MEDICATION THAT WORKS FOR SOME
OF THE STUDENTS IS THAT MEDICAL
CANNABIS.
THIS BILL WILL ALLOW A PARENT OR
GUARDIAN TO COME ON CAMPUS TO
ADMINISTER MEDICAL CANNABIS TO
THEM IN NON SMOKING AND NON
VAPING FORMS.
MANY OF THE STUDENTS NEED TO
TAKE A DOSE OF MEDICAL CANNABIS
AT REGULAR INTERVALS WHICH OFTEN
OCCURS DURING SCHOOL HOURS.
CURRENT LAW DOES NOT ALLOW ANY
FORM OF CANNABIS ON SCHOOL
GROUNDS THE STUDENTS MUST BE
PICKED UP BY THEIR PARENTS
SIGNED OUT AND TAKEN OFF CAMPUS
IN FACT OVER THOUSAND FEET AWAY.
IN ORDER TO TAKE THEIR MEDICINE
THIS IS VERY DISRUPTIVE TO THEIR
LEARNING.
SB TWO TWENTY THREE WILL ALLOW
THE GOVERNING BOARD OF A QUE TO
THROUGH TWELVE SCHOOL DISTRICT
COUNTY BOARD OF EDUCATION OR
CHARTER SCHOOL TO CHOOSE WHETHER
TO ADOPT THIS POLICY IT IS NOT A
STATE MANDATE.
DISTRICTS OR AND COUNTIES THAT
OPT IN THE CAN OPT OUT FOR ANY
REASON INCLUDING THE FEDERAL
FUNDING IS PUT AT RISK AS A
RESULT OF THIS POLICY.
SB TWO TWENTY THREE REQUIRES THE
STUDENTS TO BE A STUDENT TO BE A
QUALIFIED MEDICAL CANNABIS
PATIENT WITH A DOCTOR'S
RECOMMENDATION TYPICALLY THE
MEDICINE IS ADMINISTRATORS OIL.
AT CAPSULES DENTURES LIQUIDS OR
TOPICAL CREAMS ENVIRONMENT AND
MUST TAKE ALL CANNABIS FROM
SCHOOL GROUNDS AFTER
ADMINISTRATION.
EXISTING LAW ALLOWS SCHOOLS TO
LEGALLY ADMINISTER ANY
PHARMACEUTICAL DRUGS INCLUDING
OPIOIDS THE CHILD HAS BEEN
PRESCRIBED BUT THERE ARE MEDICAL
CONDITIONS PHARMACEUTICALS CAN'T
FIX.
AND OFTEN HAVE DEBILITATING SIDE
EFFECTS MEDICAL CANNABIS HELPS
FILL SOME OF THESE GAPS AND LESS
IN THESE CHALLENGING SIDE
EFFECTS PARENTS ACROSS THE
NATION.
HAVE HAD SUCCESS TREATING THEIR
CHILDREN WITH MEDICAL CANNABIS
WHEN NO PHARMACEUTICAL WOULD
WORK WASHINGTON COLORADO FLORIDA
MAINE AND NEW JERSEY HAVE ALL
PASSED LEGISLATION ALLOWING
STUDENTS TO USE MEDICAL CANNABIS
ON SCHOOL GROUNDS I HAVE
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT MADAM CHAIR
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR HELL WELCOME I
THINK BOTH OF YOU LADIES WERE
HERE LAST YEAR THANK YOU FOR
YOUR MOVIE TESTIMONY LAST YEAR
AND I'M SURE YOU'LL HAVE MORE
THIS YEAR PLEASE PROCEED.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS KARENA
MCCAIN I'M HERE TO SUPPORT
JUDGES ACT AS BE.
TO TWENTY THREE MY SAN GIOVANNI
JOE JOE HE MENACE HAS USE
CANNABIS AND TING SURE SEE
READING AND TEACH THE FOR THE
PAST FIVE YEARS.
SINCE THE AGE OF THREE MONTHS
OLD HE HAS BEEN PLAGUED WITH
EPILEPSY.
IN TWENTY THIRTEEN HE WAS
DIAGNOSED WITH LENNIX BECAUSE
THOSE SYNDROME.
THIS EPILEPSY IS VERY RARE.
AND HARD TO CONTROL JO JO WAS
MEDICATED WITH HIGH DOSES OF
PHARMACEUTICALS AND ALSO FITTED
WITH A DEVICE CALLED THE VAGUS
NERVE STIMULATOR.
ALL WITH NO SUCCESS.
I WAS WATCHING MY SON DIE RIGHT
BEFORE MY EYES I KNEW THERE HAD
TO BE A BETTER WAY.
I BEGAN RESEARCHING CANNABIS AND
THE EFFECTS OF IT TO TREAT
EPILEPSY.
AND TWO AND CHOSE TO TRIED AS
OUR LAST RESORT.
WE HAD TO GET A WRITTEN APPROVAL
FROM MARTYROLOGIES PRIOR TO
SEEKING A MEDICAL MARIJUANA --
RECOMMENDATION.
AND ALSO A DOCTOR TO TREAT
MINORS NOT ALL DO.
FEBRUARY TWENTY FOURTEEN WAS THE
FIRST TIME WE TRIED CANNABIS
DIDN'T SEEM VERY HOPEFUL.
DAY BY DAY I SEEN THEM EMERGE
FROM IS MEDICATED STATE START
ENGAGING AGAIN SEIZURES WERE
DECREASED IMMEDIATELY.
I SUPPORT THIS BILL TO TO JUDGE --
NEEDING A DOES THAT SCHOOL
TWELVE P..
I FEEL CAN IS SHOULD BE TREATED
AS EVERY OTHER CONTROLLED
SUBSTANCE ON SCHOOL CAMPUS IT IS
NOT FAIR THAT THIS MEDICINE IS
SAVED MY SON'S LIFE.
AND NOT BE GIVEN THE SAME
ABILITY.
AND TREATMENT AS OTHER
PHARMACEUTICALS ON ON SCHOOL
CAMPUS.
I LOOK FORWARD TO THIS BILL
BECOMING LAW.
MY SON'S LIFE WITH SO MANY
OTHERS DEPEND ON IT.
IN FIVE THOUSAND YEARS NO ONE
HAS DIED FROM CANNABIS USE.
IT IS THE ONLY MEDICINE THAT CAN
TREAT SO MANY DIFFERENT ELEMENTS
ON SUCH A WIDE SPECTRUM FROM
EPILEPSY TO ARTHRITIS TO CANCER
TO PARKINSON'S.
IT ALSO HAS THE ABILITY TO
REGENERATE BRAIN CELLS THIS SET
HAVE SEEN FIRST HAND WITH MY
CHILD.
ASK YOU FROM THE BOTTOM OF MY
HEART TO GIVE A YES VOTE TODAY.
BE THE VOICE MY SON NEEDS AND SO
MANY OTHERS NEED.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND YOUR
COMPASSION.
HUMANS BECAME PLEASE PROCEED.
GOOD MORNING SENATORS.
MY NAME IS JENNIFER KURDISH I AM
A WIFE.
AND A MOM TO FIVE YEAR OLD
ZACHARY HE'S ALMOST SIX HIM ALSO
IN INTENSIVE CARE NURSE AT A
LEVEL TWO TRAUMA CENTER IN SAN
JOSE -- I
TOLD YOU LAST YEAR ABOUT ZACHRY
AND HIS EPILEPSY AND HOW I WAS
VERY AGAINST TRYING CANNABIS --
BUT THE UPDATE SINCE THEN IS
THAT HE'S LEARNED HIS ABCS.
AND HE KNOWS HOW TO COUNT.
TO TWENTY AND HE'S IN A GARDEN
SCHOOL --
THE MIRACLE MEDICATION THAT
SAVED HIS LIFE IT'S REQUIRED FOR
SEIZURE CONTROL WITHOUT FORCING
HIM OUT OF THE CLASSROOM BECAUSE
OF OUTDATED LAWS AND
MISINFORMATION.
TODAY IS DAY ONE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY EIGHT OF THE SCHOOL YEAR.
EACH DAY WE GO TO SCHOOL TO
POINT OUT OF CLASS WALKING A
THOUSAND FEET FROM CAMPUS.
AND GIVEN THAT TO BRING HIM BACK.
THIS WHOLE PROCESS TAKES ABOUT
THIRTY MINUTES AND THAT'S ON A
GOOD DAY.
THAT ACCOUNTS 410% OF HIS DAY AT
SCHOOL.
SO FAR THIS YEAR THAT LOST TIME
EQUALS TO THREE THOUSAND EIGHT
HUNDRED AND FORTY MINUTES OR
SIXTY FOUR HOURS OF SCHOOL TIME.
AND I HAVEN'T EVEN ADDRESSED THE
OTHER TWELVE KIDS IN CLASS THEIR
DISRUPTED NOR THE TRANSITION
TIME THAT RECALL THAT IS
REQUIRED WHEN HE COMES BACK TO
CLASS WE HAVE TO PULL HIM FROM.
FROM SCHOOL.
BY THE END OF THE YEAR HE WILL
LOST ALMOST NINETY HOURS OF
SCHOOL TIME JUST SO THAT HE CAN
RECEIVE HIS MEDICATION IT MAKES
AVAILABLE TO LEARN.
HE SHOULD BE ABLE TO RECEIVE IS
MET ON CAMPUS JUST LIKE ANY
OTHER CHILD WE ARE CURRENTLY
BEING FORCED TO CHOOSE BETWEEN
HIS MEDICAL NEEDS AND THE
EDUCATION THAT HE REQUIRES.
IT'S UNCONSCIONABLE AND I
BELIEVE IT MUST BE CHANGED
PLEASE ALLOW ZACHRY TO REGAIN
LOST 10% OF SCHOOL TIME IN VOTE
YES ON THIS BILL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISS COULD
WISH AND THAT'S A NICE UPDATE
THAT'S GREAT TO HEAR.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT PLEASE PROCEED
ERICA HOFFMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION VERY MUCH IN SUPPORT
OF THIS FOR ALL THE REASONS BOTH
OF THESE MOTHERS MENTIONED IT
DOES HELP WITH STUDENTS
EDUCATIONAL NEEDS THANK YOU.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
AND ONE COME FROM CALIFORNIA
NORMAL ON BEHALF OF OUR MEMBERS
AND THEIR CHILDREN WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
THE OTHER MEMBERS ARE ANY OTHER
FOLKS IN SUPPORT.
ALL RIGHT ANY OPPOSITION DON'T
GO ANSWER.
COME ON DOWN.
WELCOME.
ACTUAL SCHOOL DISTRICT.
I AM A SUPPORT VERY GOOD THANK
YOU SIR.
ANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE ANYONE
IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING AND HEARING THAT WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS CONCERNS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
YES.
THANK YOU MA'AM TRY JUST HAVE A
COMMENT I REALLY APPRECIATE THE
FACT THAT YOU BROUGHT THIS BILL
BACK -- THIS
IS A VERY EFFECTIVE REMEDY
THAT'S UNFORTUNATE BEEN SPEAK AS
TO AS TO MY TIES TO AND NOT USED
TO SCRAPE ITS AVAILABILITY.
EVEN THE FEDERAL FTA LAST YEAR
APPROVED A DRIVE THAT CONTAINS
CANNABIS IN THE TREATMENT OF
EPILEPSY.
AND I BELIEVE THERE'S A WIDER
APPLICATIONS EVEN THE NAPA
ABSOLUTE EPILEPSY FOR THIS SO
I'M HAPPY TO AGAIN SUPPORT YOUR
BILL THIS YEAR.
THANK YOU SENATOR WORKCENTRE PAN.
THANK YOU --
CERTAINLY AS A PHYSICIAN I
APPRECIATE WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO
DO WITH THE BILL LAST YEAR IT
WILL SERVE FOR AGAIN THIS YEAR --
I I DO THINK THERE YOU KNOW WELL
THERE IS SOME CAUTION IN TERMS
OF YOU KNOW WE NEED TO HAVE GOOD
SCIENTIFIC EVIDENCE FOR WHAT.
THE CAMPUS IS ACTUALLY TRULY
EFFECTIVE --
FOR PART OF THE CHALLENGE OF
COURSE IS THAT BEING A SCHEDULE
ONE DRUG IT'S VERY HARD TO DO
THAT RESEARCH AND I THINK SO WE
WHEN WE LOOK AT CAMPUS POLICY
OVERALL WE NEED TO MAKE IT MORE
AVAILABLE FOR THE RESEARCH WE
CAN ACTUALLY.
THE SIDE THAT BUT I CERTAINLY
AGREE THAT WE SHOULD TREAT IT
LIKE -- A
PRESCRIPTION MEDICATION AND SO --
AND THAT --
THE CHILD NEEDS AT SCHOOL THEY
NEED TO BE ABLE TO GET AT SCHOOL
SO I'M SORRY PLEASE SUPPORT THE
BILL TODAY.
THANK YOU CENTER PAN ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OKAY VERY GOOD.
I WOULD TO JUST SAY THANK YOU
YOU'RE DOING WHAT MOM STILL
SUPPORTING YOUR KIDS AND MAKING
A DIFFERENCE THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE TODAY.
AND WHICH I TO CLOSE VERY MUCH
MADAM CHAIR AND THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES FOR YOUR PREVIOUS
SUPPORT AND WE SHOULD YOUR
COMMENTS TODAY I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR MICHAEL.
THANK YOU HAVE A MOTION --
MOVED THANK YOU CENTER GLAZER
MAN SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
ITEM FIVE SB TWO TO THREE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO JUDICIARY
LEYVA.
LEYVA AYE WILK AYE WILK AYE A
CHIANG SIR GLAZER AYE MCGUIRE
PAN.
PAN AYE.
ENOUGH VOTES TO GET OUT BUT WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN
CONGRATULATIONS THANK YOU GO IF
YOU'RE WELCOME.
YOU'RE WELCOME THANK YOU.
A MEMBERS WHILE WE WAIT CENTER
GLAZER WE HAVE YOU UP NEXT BUT
WHY DON'T WE GO AHEAD AND ADOPT
THE CURRICULUM POLICY.
CENTER MOVED THANK YOU.
MA'AM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL LEYVA AYE LEYVA AYE WILK
AYE WILK I CHIANG TO WRESTLE.
LUNA SO I GLAZER GLAZER AYE
MCGUIRE PAN.
PAN I THANK YOU CENTER GLAZER
.
WARNING WARNING CENTER GLAZER
BEGIN WHENEVER YOU'RE READY
THANK YOU THANK YOU SIERRA.
CHARLIE THAT I'VE MEMBERS I SP.
FOURTEEN WOULD AUTHORIZE IN A
BILLIONDOLLAR BOND FOR THE
MARCH TWENTY TWENTY BALLOT. FOR
FACILITIES AT THE CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY AND THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA.
IT'S BEEN MORE THAN A DECADE
SINCE CALIFORNIA VOTERS HAVE
BEEN ASKED TO DEDICATE FUNDS TO
BUILD AND REPAIR.
OUR HIGHER EDUCATION CLASSROOMS
RESEARCH LABS IN LIBRARIES
ACROSS OUR STATE.
AND NO HIGHER EDUCATION SPECIFIC
BOND HAS BEEN PASSED SINCE.
NINETEEN NINETY TWO ALL THE BOND
DOLLARS FOR HIGHER EDUCATION
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT WE LAST
RECEIVED IN TWO THOUSAND SIX
HAVE BEEN USED.
AND PROJECTS ARE BEING SIDELINED
AT THE CSU AND YOU SEE AS THEY
FIND A WAY TO MAINTAIN OLD
BUILDINGS AND FACILITIES. TO
ADDRESS SHORTAGES IN KEEP PACE
WITH TECHNOLOGICAL ADVANCES.
BOTH INSTITUTIONS WILL NEED MORE
TORIES ONLINE CAPACITY ANOTHER
FACILITIES.
THE BOND MONEY IN THIS BILL
COULD BE USED FOR CONSTRUCTION.
RECONSTRUCTION AND REMODELING OF
EXISTING OR NEW FACILITIES AND
TO KEEP OUR STUDENTS AND FACULTY
SAVE -- IN
THE EVENT OF AN EARTHQUAKE.
ACCORDING TO BOTH SYSTEMS AND
YOU'LL HEAR FROM THEM IN A
MOMENT.
THEY HAVE CAPITAL NEEDS IN
EXCESS OF SIXTEEN BILLION
DOLLARS WE KNOW HOW IMPORTANT IS
HIGHER EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS
ARE TO OUR STATE.
WE HAVE A VISION THAT PREPARES A
FOR OUR FUTURE --
AND STUDENTS NEED TO BE EQUIPPED
WITH THE CLASSROOMS LIBRARIES
AND LABS THAT CAN PREPARE THEM
TO BE GREAT LEADERS OF OUR STATE.
I THINK THE VOTERS DESERVE AN
OPPORTUNITY GET TO BE ABLE --
TO VOTE ON MAINTAINING AND
IMPROVING OUR UNIVERSITIES AND
COLLEGES WITH THAT I ASKED FOR
AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR GLAZER FOLKS
IN SUPPORT PLEASE PROCEED GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
JASON MURPHY ON BEHALF THE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA --
PLEASED TO BE HERE TODAY AND CO
SPONSORSHIP OF THIS BILL AND
WHAT THANK THE SENATOR FOR
BRINGING THIS IMPORTANT BILL
FORWARD.
AS WAS NOTED THE UNIVERSITY DOES
HAVE SIGNIFICANT NEEDS ARE
CAPITAL FINANCIAL PLAN --
NOTES APPROX WE EIGHT POINT
EIGHT PROJECTS ARE AVAILABLE FOR
FUNDING AT THIS TIME AND WE DO
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
HAVE THIS CONVERSATION I DID
BRING A TOTAL EXPERT WITH ME
LIKE TO HAVE HIM DO SOME SELF AS
WELL THIS MOMENT.
I THANK YOU PLEASE PROCEED I
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR AND AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS DUCK STAMPS
AND I'M THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF CAPITAL ASSETS STRATEGIES.
AT THE UNIVERSE OF CALIFORNIA
OFFICE THE PRESIDENT IN MY GROUP
OVERSEES A CAPITAL PROGRAMS AT
YOU SEE FROM A SYSTEM WIDE --
PERSPECTIVE.
MY REMARKS THIS MORNING --
ARE ARE VERY SHORT BUT I'M
AVAILABLE AT YOUR CONVENIENCE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE AND THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH YOU
THIS MORNING.
THE UNIVERSITY HAS A VERY LARGE
CAPITAL NEED INCLUDING FOR
ENROLLMENT GROWTH BOTH PASSED IN
ROMAN GROWTH AND PERSPECTIVE
ENROLLMENT GROWTH.
A FOR SEISMIC IN LIFE SAFETY --
RETROFITS AND REPLACEMENTS.
AND A TO SUPPORT AN AGING
PHYSICAL PLANT OVER 55% OF OUR
STATE ELIGIBLE.
SPACES OVER THIRTY YEARS OLD.
THE PROPOSED HIGHER EDUCATION
FACILITIES BOND ACT WOULD
GREATLY BENEFIT YOU SEE STUDENTS.
FACULTY AND STAFF AND BY
EXTENSION THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
AND WE REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT OF
THAT ACT AND I'D BE DELIGHTED
AGAIN TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THE CHAIR OR THE COMMITTEE MAY
HAPPEN THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THIS TIME.
THANK YOU.
PLEASE PROCEED [inaudible]
WITH.
I THINK I JUST TURNED IT OFF.
GOOD MORNING --
I MERRY MORE WITH THIS CSU AND
WE'RE ALSO PLEASED TO BE CO CO
SPONSORING THE BILL WITH OUR
COLLEAGUES --
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO THANK SENATOR
GLAZER FOR OFFERING THIS --
MEASURE AS SENATOR GLAZERS SAID
ARE CAN'T CAMPUSES ARE IN GREAT
NEED OF ASSISTANCE WITH OUR
FACILITIES --
ELASTIC YOU'LL FIND WITH A
FUNDING WITHIN TWO TWO THOUSAND
SIX AND THAT MONEY HAS BEEN
DRIED UP.
MORE THAN HALF OF CS USE
FACILITY SPACES OVER FORTY YEARS
OLD AND THE THIRD IS OVER FIFTY
YEARS THE RESULT.
THE FOUR BILLION DOLLARS SHARE
THE BOND FOR HELP US TO ADDRESS
DEFICIENCIES IN OUR OLDER
BUILDINGS AND PROVIDE SAFER UP
UPDATED AND MORE RELIABLE
FACILITIES WHERE OUR STUDENTS
FACULTY AND STAFF.
CAN LEARN AND AND WORK.
IT WOULD ALSO ALLOW US TO
MODERNIZE OUR CLASSROOMS BASED
TO KEEP UP WITH CURRENT WORK
WORK FORCE TRANS.
AND IT WOULD ALLOW US TO GROW
OUR CAMP CAMPUSES TO THAT WE
COULD SERVE ADDITIONAL STUDENTS.
AND I'D LIKE TO INTRODUCE OUR
CSU FACILITY.
EXPERT.
THANK YOU PLEASE PROCEED A GOOD
MORNING CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
BOARD MY NAME IS A VIRUS AND ONE
OF THE SYSTEM VICE CHANCELLOR
FOR CAPITAL PLANNING DESIGN
CONSTRUCTION FOR THE CSU.
AND I I HOPE YOU SUPPORT THIS
MEASURE THIS BOND EFFORT IT'S
NICE TO SEE A FORMER TRUSTEE
BACK IN IN PERSON.
THE AS MERRY MENTION WE HAVE
TREMENDOUS NEEDS AND THE CSU
PRIORITIES FOR THE CAPITAL
PROGRAM FOLLOW THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S PARTY SETTING WITH
FIRE LIFE SAFETY.
AND REINVESTMENT INTO EXISTING
FACILITIES IN OUR IN OUR FIVE
YEAR PLAN OUT OF THE TEN BILLION
ABOUT A BILLION DOLLARS OF THAT
WOULD ADDRESS SEISMIC SAFETY IN
THE CSU.
AND THAT TEN BILLION IS A
CONSTRAINT NUMBER BECAUSE WE
LIMIT HOW MANY PROJECTS THE
CAMPUS CAN REQUEST SO THERE'S
PROBABLY GREATER NEED BUT BASED
ON THE AVAILABLE FUNDS WE
CONSTRAIN THAT AMOUNT.
WE HAVE A FIVE YEAR PLAN WE
PRODUCE ANNUALLY SO IT HAS A
LIST OF PROJECTS THAT HAVE BEEN
FUNDED IN THE LAST FIVE YEARS IN
THE FIVE YEARS FORWARD.
IT INCLUDES THOSE PROJECTS THAT
WOULD BE.
A LOT OF THEM ARE AT POMONA SAN
FRANCISCO WITH SOME OF THE FAULT
ISSUES IN THOSE AREAS.
LOS ANGELES AND AND A IN
ADDITION.
SO I THINK IT'S A REALLY WHAT
WE'VE DONE IN THE CSU IS WE
FOCUS ON EXISTING FACILITIES
WITH OF FUNDS WE'VE HAD IN THE
PAST CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND IN THE FUTURE WE SEE OF
GOING FORWARD ADDRESSING
RESILIENCE WITH THE NUMBER OF
FLIGHTS THAT HAVE --
THE IMPACT OF FLOODING AND FIRES
ACROSS OUR CAMPUSES SAYS WHERE
WE PUT SOME OF THE FUTURE FUNDS
FROM THE HIGHER AND BOND SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING WELCOME A HANNAH
BRAG START WITH THE CAL STATE
STUDENT ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING I ROSE AND I'M A
SOPHOMORE AT UC BERKELEY AND WE
ARE STRONGLY IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
HI ANDY GARCIA CHAVEZ FROM UC
BERKELEY OF WE ARE STRONGLY IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS MAP BROAD
WITH THE TEAMSTERS IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
ADAM TURNED MEMBERS SYLVIA'S
ALICIA ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
WE DO NOT YET HAVE A FORMAL
POSITION ON THE BILL WERE MORE
AT WE HAVE SUPPORTING CONCEPT AN
INTERIM SUPPORTING CONCEPTS
ADDITION AS WE DO RECOGNIZE THE
GREAT GREAT NEED. FOR MORE
FACILITY FUNDING HOWEVER WE
WOULD ASK FOR A CLOSER LOOK AT
THE FORMULA THE FUNDING FORMULA
AS THE CSU HAS TWICE THE NUMBER
OF CAMPUSES AND TWICE THE NUMBER
OF STUDENTS SO WE ASK FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION AND THAT AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH.
THE AUTHOR SENATOR GLAZER THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
A NURSE HOUSING CAN YOU SEE
SINICIZATION LITERALLY JUST FLEW
IN LA FOR THIS MOMENT IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
IT IS OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE ANY IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING AND HEARING THEN WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
TO SEE WHEN I'M THE QUESTION
CENTER PAN.
THANK YOU CHAIR LEYVA --
SO FOR FIRST OF ALL I AGREE WITH
YOU THAT THERE ARE TREMENDOUS
NEEDS I SEE THEM THE CAMPUSES IN
MY DISTRICT --
I ALSO YOU KNOW DO MAKE NOTE
THAT -- THE
LAST TIME WE HAD A BOND WAS I
GUESS THE QUESTION I HAVE
CERTAINLY I'D IMAGINE THEY SEE
THE NEED I SUPPORT --
THIS LEGISLATION BUT WE SEE THIS
ALSO K. THROUGH TWELVE ALSO SO
WHAT HAPPENS IS THAT WE DO SORT
OF THE BIG BANG BOND HER EIGHT
SO AND THIS IS GOING TO COST US
FOUR HUNDRED MILLION A YEAR SO
YOU KNOW IT'S EIGHT BILLION
DOLLAR BOND FOR TWO MILLION A
YEAR. FOR THE TO PAY BACK BOND.
HOWEVER GENERAL FUND THEN --
DO WE HAVE IS IS THERE SOME
THOUGHT ABOUT.
LIKE TO JUST DO THIS X. EVERY EX
NUMBER YEARS OR IS THERE SOME
THOUGHT ABOUT A MORE SUSTAINABLE
WAY OF HANDLING --
THE INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS THAT.
SO SO I APPRECIATE THAT WE HAVE
A GAP AND WE NEED TO DO
SOMETHING --
BUT ALSO --
THIS IN ITSELF.
AND YOU SAID THE NEEDS STILL
GREATER THAN WHAT'S IN THIS BOND
IS NOT SERVE AN ON GOING
APPROACH AND I'M NOT SAYING THAT
EVERYTHING HAS TO TAKE CARE OF
EVERYTHING BUT SINCE WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT THE TOPIC I WAS
WONDERING WHETHER MAYBE PERHAPS.
SOME OF THE WITNESSES MIGHT
WANNA DRESS --
WHAT YOU SEE IS?
HOW WOULD YOU TAKE CARE OF?
THE ADDITIONAL NEEDS THE ONGOING
IS BECAUSE THE BUILT BUILDINGS
WILL CONTINUE TO WEAR OUT AGENT
SO FORTH RIGHT DAVE BEYOND --
SUMI THIS PASSES.
ANYONE WANT TO ANSWER.
PLEASE PROCEED --
PANEL ALL TAKES OUT THERE'S NO
EASY ANSWER THERE IT IS THE
AMOUNT OF OF FUNDING FOR FOR A
MAINTENANCE OF THE FACILITIES.
WE ESTIMATED NEED ABOUT THREE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
ANNUALLY TO ADDRESS BUILDING
SYSTEMS THAT HAVE A REACH THE
END OF THEIR USEFUL LIFE.
AND IN OUR SPORT BUDGET WERE
VERY HAPPY MAINTENANCE FOR THE
CSU.
BUT ALL AS ONGOING BASIS IT
WOULD BE THAT AMOUNT OF MONEY
THE TO ADDING FORTY SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS MORE.
PLUS ANOTHER HUNDRED MILLION TO
ADDRESS ONGOING NEED AS PART OF
OUR BASE BUDGET SO THERE'S NO
EASY ANSWER THERE AND IN MY
SENSE.
THANK YOU SENATOR PAN ANYTHING
ELSE.
GO AHEAD OF A JUST GOOD AT THE
THE FIRST CALIFORNIA WOULD
CONCUR WITH OUR COLLEAGUES THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY WE
RECOGNIZE THAT THERE WILL BE.
ADDITIONAL NEEDS ON A GOING
FORWARD BASIS I WOULD HOWEVER
NOTE THAT --
THE OTHER ARE PROJECTS TO THE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA AND OUR
COLLEAGUES OF CALIFORNIA
UNIVERSITY ARE FUNDING.
INTERNALLY --
TO HELP ADDRESS THIS PROBLEM BUT
WE DO FEEL THAT --
STATE BOND WOULD BE APPROPRIATE
ANALYST PORTIONS SLOWED.
OKAY SO I APPRECIATE THOSE
ANSWERS I MEAN PART OF IT ALSO
WONDERING ABOUT TO WHAT DEGREE
DO SHOULD WE DO THIS THROUGH THE
BUDGET PROCESS RIGHT AND MAYBE
IT'S AN SOME.
MECHANISM BY WHICH YOU KNOW
WHETHER IT'S TO PUT MONEY TO FOR
A BOND OR SOMETHING OF THAT
NATURE FOUR ON ROLLING BOND OR
SOME SOME OTHER NATURE SO THAT.
BECAUSE THIS IS SO THAT WE'RE
NOT JUST BECAUSE I SEE THIS AS
IMPACT ON THE BUDGET BUT BERSERK
BUT IT'S IT'S NOT THE QUESTIONS
ALREADY.
CONSIDERING THIS AND FOR
STRUCTURE PEACE IN OUR CURRENT
BUDGETING PROCESS AND MAYBE
THAT'S WHICH YOU SHOULD BE
THINKING ABOUT THIS KIND OF
MECHANISMS.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR PAN MISTER
VICE CHAIR.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
SOUTH DAKOTA EIGHT HUNDRED SIXTY
FIVE THOUSAND PEOPLE. SEVEN
PUBLIC FOUR YEAR COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES.
I REPRESENT NINE HUNDRED SEVENTY
ONE THOUSAND PEOPLE THREE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES ONE SMALL --
SEE ISSUE BAKERSFIELD EDUCATION
CENTER ENOUGH LANCASTER THAT WE
ARE GOING TO BE EXPANDING --
THANKS TO A BOND MEASURE WE
PASSED LAST YEAR.
BUT IN THE BILL HE SAID A UNDER
BOTTOM FORCES THE CONSTRUCTION
OF IMPROVEMENTS AT OFF CAMPUS
BUT IT INCLUDES MONEY FOR
CONSTRUCTION OF OUR IMPROVEMENTS
SAID.
CONSTRUCTION OR IMPROVEMENTS OF
OFF CAMPUS FACILITIES --
FOR C. ISSUES IT WITH THAT UP
ENTER -- I I
A WOULD DOES DIFFER COLLEAGUES
HERE -- TO
TO GIVE A SPECIFIC ANSWER THERE
I YES.
COULD BE MORE SPECIFIC --
WELL NOT NOW I'M FINE WITH THAT.
YES IS GOOD.
ALL RIGHT WITH.
A DANCER AND I AM PREGNANT I'M A
CO AUTHOR THIS WHOLE MONTHLY
APPRECIATE THEM THE WORK YOU'RE
DOING I JUST FEEL LIKE YOU KNOW
YOUR ZIP CODE SHOULD NOT BE AN
IMPEDIMENT. TO ACCESSING
EDUCATION AND WE'RE MAKING ALL
THESE INVESTMENTS IN THESE YOUNG
PEOPLE AND THEY'RE LEAVING AND
NOT COMING BACK HAVE A HUNDRED
TEN THOUSAND COMMUTERS GOING OUT
ANA BALLY EVERY DAY TO LA.
NUMBER EIGHTY TWO THOUSAND
LEAVING THE VICTOR VALLEY GOING
DOWN THE INLAND EMPIRE AND WE
WOULD SURE LIKE TO BUILD
SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITIES THERE.
AND I THINK THE MOST IMPORTANT
COMPONENT MISSING IS HIGHER
EDUCATION SO.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR EFFORTS
SENATOR.
THANK YOU MISTER VICE CHAIR ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD I THINK THIS IS KIND OF
A NON SEXY BILL THAT WE FORGET
ABOUT WE FORGET HOW CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT.
OUR INFRASTRUCTURE IS SO THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD
CENTER GLAZER WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE THANK YOU CHAIR LEYVA I
WOULD JUST SAY.
THANK YOU TO MY CO AUTHOR
SENATOR WILK AND THE CENTER
ALLEN IS JOINTLY AUTHORING THE
BILL WITH ME.
AND FOR MANY OTHERS WHO
RECOGNIZED THAT OUR INSTITUTIONS
OF HIGHER LEARNING ARE SO
IMPORTANT IN OUR STATE.
SO IMPORTANT TO OUR ECONOMIC
VITALITY SO IMPORTANT OF THE
FAMILIES AND THEIR THEIR KIDS
THAT THAT HIGHER EDUCATION FOR
THEM -- BUT
YOU KNOW WE HAVE A WE HAVE
IGNORED THIS PROBLEM. FOR A LONG
TIME AND TO ADDRESS THE QUESTION
IS SENATOR PAN --
ASKED EARLIER IF WE DON'T HANDLE
IT THROUGH --
CAPITAL OUTLAY BOND --
THEN THE PRESSURES ON THE
INSTITUTION ARE TO DO IT
THEMSELVES WHICH PUTS PROVIDE
DIRECT PRESSURE ON TUITION
INCREASES --
AT OUR IN OUR SYSTEMS AND THAT'S
REALLY THE BACKSTOP THAT IF WE
DON'T ACT THAT THEY WILL AND
IT'S NOT THE ACT THAT THAT THE
RECOURSE WE'D LIKE TO SEE.
THESE INSTITUTIONS HAVE BEEN
BUILT BY THE TAXPAYERS OF
CALIFORNIA ALL OF US BECAUSE OF
THEIR IMPORTANCE TO OUR STATE.
NOT JUST FOR THE KIDS IN THE
FAMILIES BUT FOR ALL OF US AT
SUPPORT THAT ALL OF US INVEST IN
THE PAINT MAINTENANCE OF THOSE
FACILITIES AND THAT'S WHAT THIS
BOND DOES IT DOES PUT ON THE
BALLOT. FOR THE VOTERS TO DECIDE
YES THERE IS A OPERATING COST
OBLIGATION.
BUT IT DOES MEAN THAT THAT
STUDENTS AND THEIR FAMILIES WILL
BE THE ONES TO BEAR THE SPECIFIC
BURDEN.
OF EARTHQUAKE SAFETY AND FIRE
SAFETY AND FLOOD SAFETY
ELECTRICAL SYSTEMS ALL OF US
WILL SHARE AND THAT AS WE HAVE
HISTORICALLY CALIFORNIA AND WITH
THAT I ASKED FOR IT EITHER.
THANK YOU CENTER GLAZER DO WE
HAVE A MOTION --
MOVED THANK YOU MA'AM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ITEM ONE SB FOURTEEN THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE LEYVA.
LEYVA AYE WILK AYE WILK AYE A
CHIANG WHO WRESTLES.
WRESTLE AYE GLAZER AYE GLAZER
AYE MCGUIRE PAN WE WILL LEAVE IT
OPEN FOR MEMBERS TO ADD ON THANK
YOU FOR COMING TODAY.
MEMBERS BEFORE WE VOTE ON
CONSENT DOES ANYONE HAVE
ANYTHING THEY WOULD LIKE TO
REMOVE THE ONE ITEM FROM CONSENT
[inaudible]
YES.
ALL RIGHT TO HAVE A MOTION THANK
YOU DOCTOR PAN AND SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
A LEYVA AYE LEYVA AYE WILK HI
WILK I CHANGED TO WRESTLE. TO
WRESTLE AYE GLAZER.
GLAZER AYE MCGUIRE PAN
[inaudible]
HI.
THANK YOU THE CONSENT CALENDAR
IS CONFIRMED.
WE BELIEVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
CENTER MCGUIRE TO COME IN AB ON
I UNDERSTAND THAT SENATOR CHIANG
IS OUT BILL.
MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH HAVE
A GREAT REST TODAY THANK YOU ALL
FOR BEING HERE
THE ROLE SO THAT
SENATOR MCGUIRE COMBAT MADAM
SECRETARY.
ITEM ONE SB FOURTEEN THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I
ADVISED HER VOTING I FIVE ZERO
CHIANG MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE.
THAT BILL IS OUT SIX ZERO THANK
YOU.
ITEM TWO SB FIFTY SIX THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I VICE CHAIR VOTING I'VE
FIVE ZERO CHIANG REQUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE.
THAT VOTERS OUT. SIX ZERO FOR
THE BILL'S OUT EXCUSE ME.
ITEM FIVE AS BE TWO TO THREE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO JUDICIARY
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I VICE
CHAIR VOTING I FIVE ZERO CHANGE.
MCGUIRE AYE. SIX ZERO THAT
VOTERS OUT AS WELL.
WE'VE GOT ONE MORE FOR YEAH --
TO EXCUSE ME CONSENT CALENDAR
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I'D VICE
CHAIR VOTING I FIVE ZERO CHIANG
MCGUIRE MCGUIRE AYE.
VERY GOOD THAT IS OUT AS WELL --
CURRICULUM POLICY WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I A VICE CHAIR VOTING I
FIVE ZERO CHIANG MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE VERY GOOD THE
CURRICULUM POLICY IS ADOPTED
THANK YOU SENATOR MCGUIRE.
ACTOR COMMITTEE HAVE FUN THANK
YOU EVERYONE.
WE ARE OFFICIALLY ADJOURNED